Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot!
We're gonna go right back into it because I don't have time to sit around and mull over my fate.
I have to go charging in blindly into the madness and carry on, and this might be a boss fight
I have no idea, but it wouldn't make sense if it was a boss fight, would it?
Oh, it is a boss fight! Hi! Hey, well you're not even gonna explain yourself? How do you explain yourself?
What do you have to say for yourself big guy? Oh, hi? Okay? Yeah, whatever. Oh wait. Are you not a boss? Oh, you're not?
That's why you didn't---- yeah, you're right get out of here with your rubyness. oh you think you got me worried for a second there. I still think that you could be uh ah ah sorry
Aha! Oh no, your barrels loved you so much that they just disappeared when you died.
*Aku Aku noise*
Alright Booga-Booga, here we go.
Agh! (grunting moan)
(Surprised scream) okay
Well, thank you for being here with me for this momentary adventure. I'll never forget the times we shared Mr. Mask Man!
I'll leave those for posterity.
Okay, do we have another guy? Oh!
Are you mad just cause' I killed your brother? Oh, man. I've killed many a' siblings in this game apparently. Oh, okay
bye, then. Oh that poor pig that had to see his whole family die. Yeah, and if again, you're confused,
I'll put a link to the live stream that I did. It was two hours of this and I got...
*sighs* I got mad. I got Aaangry! *nasty midsentence burp* Ooh, I got mad, okay. Hey!
Hidey-Hidey, Hidey-Ho. Ugh!
Ga-booinga, Ga-booing. *chime* Ding-dong!
Aw Frick!
Well this one isn't so bad
I gotta admit, this one is actually is kind of relaxing with all the glorious loveliness that it is. Oh,
Your barrel went back. Ah, so polite even after death you put things away.
All right, oh, we done rolling barrels? Is there no one left alive to roll barrels? Whoa, I don't like that!
It's donkey kong up in here. Ah!
*Mark screams* I DON'T KNOW HOW TO time you!
*Mark moans* When's the last, yeah, when did I hit a checkpoint? I have no idea. Oh, excuse you! What?
(Mark panics while screaming)
I don't know what happened. I don't like it though. I do not know, I do not care. That was not cool whatever happened there.
AGH! *Another grunting moan*
Cause' I like slid off, and then I recalibrated wrong.
*Makes Aku Aku noise* NO! *Continues making Aku Aku noise*
Okay, I don't know how to deal with the bouncy-boos. I think the bouncy-boos are just hell on Earth.
Okay, here comes a bouncy-boo, but I can beat it there. Okay. We're just gonna, oh boy, je, ah
Goo I, I guess! Ah! Oh no, oh no, Oh no, Oh no, OH NO?! NO, AAH?
Oh, I made it. I survived that. I don't know how, I don't know when. Oh god. OH, I GOT SQUOOSHED!?
I don't like this.
Ah, No wonder they gave me so many lives leading up to this. I'm gonna need em'. All right, hugh!
Gooski!
See, everything bad happens immediately after I go, "Hey, this isn't so bad. I could get used to this one. It's kind of
relaxing jumping over barrels." OH GAWD HELL!?
Oh
*Short moan* He thinks that it's also probably not a good idea to be tossing toxic barrels that way. One handling them is bad, but also two -
Yeah
whoo shit
Oh boy, no, eh
Okay run, run, run, RUN! Oh God! Heh, oh man
*sings*I don't know how I made that. I don't know how I made that! Why are those extra bouncy?(That's what she said) Oh
Boinky! Okay, give me that checkpoint please. Yes. Thank you!
aye,aye,aye,aye,aye,aye,aye,aye,aye,aye!
Yeah, ugh! Ok.
I don't know why that one was there by itself. A single Wampa fruit for me. No no no no. No! No! Where you' going?
Huh, missed me by that much
*mixtures of panicky moans*
No, please. I have a family!
Okay, made that! Get in that, okay?
Oh, I'mma stop using the directional Pad because it's not good for me. Oh, maybe here. Just a little bit.
Uh
Eh
Ah, I didn't know that-would be that-in the way
I, I didn't anticipate that. I didn't anticipate it.
Eh
So, you gotta hurry, because otherwise, you're gonna be fubber-knucking boned
Okay, we did it. I think? At least we got lives and we're out of here.
*ballon deflating noise*
You guys have never been fubber-knucking boned before? Yeah, I didn't think--
AAGH!? Hey!
Okay, we're fine. Oh, yes, okay. I got your number. Oh, frick! I got it from Steve!
AGH, okay. Don't. Even. Just bounce it over my head! Okay. Yes. Thank you! Hey!
I got--
I got all of them?
Did I actually get all the boxes?
*Surprised, Mark squeals*
Nearly perfect, but you died? Well, don't give me that look just because you died and you had a clone come back!
Oh, Mr. Judgemental Bandicoot. Oh I'm sorry with your blue pants and purple shoes and tapping foot and---
*Mark struggling to roast*
2012 Markiplier hair
Fuck you, okay. Carrying on! Okay, geez. All that just to get through-- Oh no, Pinstripe Potoro!
Okay, this is Pinstripe Potoro. His Tommy gun isn't always reliable. Huh, ain't that the truth! How many times?---Oh
Oh-whoahohoho!
The shnoot on that guy! Hahahaha! Are you having fun? I don't think this chair will be able to stop this!
Whoa, ah, hey,hey!
Oh, whoa whoah! Alright, how do I?
Geh! Oh, does it straight up fighty-fight. Okay, I don't think it's very fair. Goo!
Considering you have bullets and I have... hopes and dreams.[Crash Bandicoot]:Woah! [Markiplier] OOOH!
What did you catch me with a ricochet? Did your devilish good looks get me?
[Pinstripe Potoroo]: Yah! [Crash Bandicoot]: Woah!
Okay, if I jump straight into the line of fire, that doesn't do me too good. Ah.
Shit! Nnnno. Oh you are pretty accurate with that. Who'd have thought that I wouldn't be able to dodge bullets? God, the fucking mouth
*Evil Papyrus noise*
NO!! [Crash Bandicoo]: Woah! [Markiplier] God damn, he's good. He's real good.
No, did I spun. Why didn't you die?
Heee-YAY! Oh!
I should've--*angry giberish*-- I gotta jump on his head probably. That's probably what I gotta--Don't give me that bullshit!
I don't need you! *whispers* I need you desperately!
Okay, well, I don't know what's going on. Okay?
I was--I started this adventure great, and I had a lot of fun, and now it seems like I'm being blowned.
*Markiplier's bird call*
Ugh
I don't understand that, okay. I got this every--Uh,  you didn't see anything else. I didn't actually put in any other attempts there, so it's all--
What?
Why?
Okay, I got you. So y-y-you gotta get him on the reloads.
Easy-Peasy, Lemon squeeze- Him!
He's got more. Yeah, that's right! Good  thing this chair is extremely strong!
Gabooski! Got em'! Ok! Hiding, hiding, Hiding! Hiding, hiding, HIDING! Being patient is real fun!
Heh, your really lame, like me.
Mmm. Gabooski! Why did that not get him? OOH?!
*whining* Oh, why did that not get him?!
*still whining* What a load!
What a load!
All right, all right. I got this! I got your number okay, so I'm not gonna-- I'm not gonna panic.
I'm not panicking about nothing from nobody!
Cause' I know how to deal-- Uh oh. YUGH! I didn't make it, didn't make it, didn't make it. Ooh hoo, ooh hoo, hoo, hoo
Hey.
Got him? Okay. Gotti! okay.
HAHGH!
You think he'd be smart enough to come around the other side of this chair.
Chairs' always been for me though. Always been there for me. All right, one more do-Dance. Ha, ha, ha, ha! Get ready. Oh
*Random panic noise*
Come on!
This guy's good. This guy's real good
[Pinstripe Potoroo] *laughing*. *grunts*
Haha! WHOAH, hey, hey, hey, hey!
Hey, I did it! Oh, he dead.
Ugh! Pinstripe Patooey.
Meaning that I killed him and everything's great. I think that's what that means.
Alright, we made it through that without too much tears and me sobbing like a little baby, but that's okay
cause' we got a lot more to go.Oh.
Why?
B-B-But why though?Why is that--
[Crash Bandicoot]: Woah!
[Markiplier] What is that?!
What is that?!
Hugh!
What is this bl-black Magic?
Oh black Magic woman, where am I going?
*chuckles in disbeleif* What?
I found a bonayse. I found a bonayse (bonus) I got some extra lives. That's so--
[Crash Bandicoot] Woah!
[Markiplier] Great. What, did it take em' away?
*Quietly whimpers* Dit it?
It wouldn't have done that.
[Crash Bandicoot]: Woah!
[Markiplier]: Wa, ha, ha, ha, ha!
Hahaha! Ok, I've been told--
I've been told--
you can--Oh!
That's handy! >:D
Oh, that's handy-dandy. Ohohohoho! That is handy-dandy.
Okay
Ok, just gotta be careful about it.
*whispers* ok
*Markimoo screams of panic and anguish turn into anger and frustration*
Oh boy
Okay, so this part's not that bad. I'm only gonna-- You know what?
Walking on the rope is for chumps! That seems cheati, and I'm not a cheater, so that's what I'm gonna do
TodaaAAAAAAAAAAAY
Oh, God. I hate--Hi piggy-piggy!
[Crash Bandicoot]: Woah!
[Markiplier] Okay, that's where you're gonna go. You know, before you didn't go that far, so it didn't make me think anything of it
I'm gonna forget those boxes. I don't-- I don't care about completionist at this point
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT THE PIG!?
I FORGOT ABOUT THE---*more angry giberish*
Okay. Whoo Boy. This is gonna be one of those-- nokay?
I just kept going forward then. I didn't want to go forward but I just kept going forward
How about that? How about that?
Chezzizis
Okay, all right that that's AH!, This is your stuff is it!
Turtle
Turtle Bebut
dimity
Ok. I don't need you. * 1 millisecond later* AGH, I needed you and you let me down. I am a kift!--
*whispers* fuck!
Ugh! I'm tempted to run on that rope but it's cheating. It's cheating. It's cheating. It's cheating. It's cheating. Oh boy!
NOOOOO!?
AAAAGH!? *Evil Papyrus returns*
*whispers* God damn it!
God damn it!
oh, you know, AGH okay? You just stay there, then. I guess that's what's happening here
So they just stay once you go over them. That's awfully not yet. NO!
Come ahahahahon! I'm right there!
Oh My God, I'm getting flustered. Uh!
Okay
No, not you. Uh okay. Yep, yep cute, okay?
Got that
boink, okay
No, that wasn't enough my God. That's hard to time it really is oh
NOOOOO!
[Uka Uka:] Game ovah!
[Markiplier]: Fine, why why am I timing it?
We would oh I'm an idiot! why would I time that I would just run forward at the right time no, that's
That was the wrong time
I'm not going to run on the ropes what oh so now. I have input. It doesn't matter when I fall
You know what I mean. Oh, you made me faster, and I don't know handle that
Okay, sure you're gone now
Yeah, see what I don't know why I was doing that when I could just do
Oh come on!
[Uka Uka]: Game ovah!
[Markiplier]: I'm getting all kind of flustered. This is now. It should be now it should be oh
I'm a persistent bastard
Yeah, you just get out of sitting off in the distance over there
Don't think I didn't see that out of the corner of my eye
Okay, but this is what I meant why don't I just do this?
And then I go the distance that I need to go
Okay
No
No! Why did you slide off of his side?
I saw that you piece of shit wow
What the heck ooh?
Jeezum I saw that everyone saw that
How you cheating bastard?
Oh my God. Oh, this is Gonna. Get me was it's Gonna get me
Hi, friend. I'll be on my way then
There's staring breathin right into my nose ah that was lovely I didn't do that!!
I am I gonna jump on the rope the cheaty way gonna cheater. Look at me look at how look at oh come on
Hi again, hi are you? I'm great good to hear that. Thank you for being you
You're so lovely and everything you do.
Oh fuh..!
*maniacal mix between a laugh and a cry as Mark loses his mind*
*pure frustration* WHY did that happen?!?
*utter defeat*
I don't... I'm landing right on you!!!
In my brain I am
Don't laugh at me. Okay, alright, then I'm gonna end this episode here. Don't worry. I'm not quitting
Just carrying a load in the next episode you're gonna pick it up right where I left off in the middle of madness
But I need to go calm down
So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know how I'm doing down the comments below. I know there's painful
Painful for me too good. Thanks again everybody for watching and as always. I will see you in the next
video. Buh-Bye!
*outro music plays*